Okay, guys, so we are back at the desk
again, and we have come to a very
important juncture in the PTM video
series, because we are now at the end of
the quantitative processing phase of the
trade idea generation process. So, what
have we actually looked at here? Well,
we've looked at a number of things.
Firstly, the interpretation of valuation
and growth metrics. Okay.
We've looked at the mechanics of long
processing, long trade idea processing.
We've looked at the mechanics of short
idea processing. And we've also looked at
the opportunities in non-ideal earnings
growth profiles. And we've also looked at
turnarounds and value traps. But also, we
showed you how to process data correctly
in the quant phase and avoid all of the
common
mistakes. So what we're going to do is
now, guys, we're going to go through a
thorough recap of everything in the quant
phase. And then we're going to head
straight into the next section of the
video series, the qualitative processing
phase. So guys, you're making very good
progress here. If you've got to this
stage, and understood the vast majority of
what's being taught here, you're in a
very, very strong position.
But obviously, there's a lot more work to
do in the trade idea generation process.
Keep going, get your head down. Keep
learning the material. And I'll see you
back at the desk very soon.
Okay, so we've got to go, get your head
down.
Okay, so we've come to the end of a major
part of the PTM video series. The
quantitative processing phase of trade
idea generation. Let's go through now a
recap of the quantitative processing
phase. And let's tie everything up
together.
So if you recall, in the first part of the
PTM video series, we started at the macro
economic level, we covered leading
indicators in the United States, and also
internationally.
In our overall systematic process, we
always start with the fundamentals, and we
start at the macro level. And we do this
because we want to know, and we want to
predict GDP growth, both in the United
States and internationally.
And we are seeking to forecast through
correlation, stock market direction and
returns.
Why? Because we want to know our
directional portfolio bias, long, short,
or neutral, flat.
And we also want to know, or have clues as
to the characteristics of what types of
longs and shorts we should be exposing
ourselves to.
If we understand the macro economic
environment first from the top down via
our leading indicators, we can build
portfolios that stand the best chance of
making money in the current and
forthcoming macro economic environment.
So we do our monthly processes in the
fundamentals in the quantitative at the
macro level first.
And each month we update our leading
indicators and we interpret them as to
what portfolio bias we should be having at
any one moment in time.
And of course, we always look to our macro
to identify potential stresses in the
economy and potentially in the financial
markets to enable us to change our mind
and to change our portfolio bias when
required.
Once we have established our macro
economic view and our market view or
portfolio bias, we move on to looking at
stocks at the micro level.
And we do this on a quantitative and
qualitative basis.
We will generate potential trade ideas,
both longs and shorts using the
quantitative processes in the micro
economic bottom up dashboard first.
And our starting point is always an
identification process at the sector
level, utilizing market capitalization,
percentage earnings growth, percentage
revenue growth,
and valuation price earnings ratio and peg
ratio.
Once we have identified potential longs
and shorts, we look to backwards looking
information, backwards looking quant for
evidence.
We move from identification into evidence.
So first of all, we look at enterprise
value, EBIT and EBITDA, EV over EBIT and
EV over EBITDA.
And then we move on to backwards looking
quant in the profit and loss statement,
the balance sheet and the combos, the
combo ratios of the balance sheet and the
profit and loss statement.
And then we also have a look at cash flow
statement metrics.
So this is a step in uncovering evidence
and seeking evidence as to what is behind
valuation and as to what is behind
potentially driving revenue growth and
earnings growth.
And therefore helping us to understand why
the market likes a particular stock.
And why a market dislikes a particular
stock.
In a sector.
And therefore helping us to understand why
the market likes a particular stock.
In a sector.
And therefore helping us to understand why
the market likes a particular stock.
And why a market dislikes a particular
stock.
In a sector.
And therefore helping us to understand why
the market likes a particular stock.
the market.
And therefore helping us to understand why
And why a market dislikes a particular
stock.
In a sector.
and therefore it also gives us an overall
understanding and appreciation of exactly
why a sector has positive outliers and
negative outliers and everything else in
between those outliers.
So our forward-looking metrics, our
forward-looking quant helps us to identify
the positive outliers and negative
outliers in a sector.
And our backwards-looking quant gives us
evidence and clues as to why those
positive outliers exist and why those
negative outliers exist
and helps us to understand the entire
landscape of a sector.
So how does all this quantitative work
that we've been looking at and what we
will engage in on a regular basis
actually fit into our overall pro-trader
systematic framework for long-short
portfolio management within the
20-to-60-day time horizon?
Well, it fits into the area where on a
regular basis we will be doing the vast
majority of our work.
Where we will do 80-90% of our work.
Yes, it fits into our fundamental area of
the overall pro-trader systematic
framework.
We engage in fundamental quantitative and
qualitative processes first at the macro
level to determine portfolio bias,
utilising quantitative processes as in
leading indicators,
and we utilise quantitative metrics at the
micro level, the bottom-up level,
that being our forward-looking metrics for
identification purposes
and our backwards-looking quantitative or
accounting metrics for evidence
that supports the quantitative in our
identification steps.
So it's fundamentals first and everything
else comes after that.
And we will, of course, be looking at
everything else in the PTM video series
except trade structure
because in the PTM video series, we are
assuming that we are taking stock
positions.
So to recap here on fundamentals, just
simply remember the steps that we have to
go through for fundamental analysis.
So, we have two parts to our fundamental
analysis.
We have our quantitative processes and we
have our qualitative processes.
So far, we have looked at quantitative
process where we've covered macro views
for portfolio bias
and we've covered quantitative in the
micro context for micro views.
And the quantitative process is used for
identifying outliers.
And part of that overall process of
identifying outliers with some conviction,
we also look to our backwards-looking
quantitative for evidence.
So at this stage of the fundamental
analysis, we have overall identified
potential longs and shorts
utilizing quantitative processes.
The next step in the process, which is
what we're moving on to now in the PTM
video series is the qualitative process.
And this comes in a number of steps,
learning the stock info, identifying key
performance indicators and identifying
catalysts.
As a reminder, while we're recapping
quantitative, we go where the juice is.
Our opportunity set in the U.S. stock
market is over 2,200 stocks.
And we have various industry sectors that
can be characterized as cyclicals and
defensives.
And within those sectors, we have various
stocks that can be characterized as
growth, X growth and value.
And of course, we are always seeking as
traders to get the most juice out of the
squeeze.
We want to be long stocks, positive
outliers that, within our time horizon,
are going to both outperform their sector
and the market in any GDP growth
environment.
And on the short side, we want to be
short, negative outliers, we want to be
short stocks that go down.
We want to be short stocks that
underperform both the sector and the
market in any GDP environment.
So we always start with our quantitative
processes at the sector and the stock
level of forward-looking, quantitative
processes in order to identify both
positive and negative outliers within a
sector.
So in this exercise of discovery, we look
to our forward-looking metrics in order to
make the identification of positive and
negative outliers.
So we look to market cap, earnings growth,
revenue growth, and valuation, PE and PEG.
And the processes that we will engage in
for each, for example, are as follows.
So for market capitalization, we are going
to put market cap filters on our sector
data for longs and shorts.
And we are going to look at annualized
historical and implied volatility of each
of those stocks.
And in terms of volatility, what we are
looking for is roughly around at least 1.5
times the S&P 500 volatility index.
The VIX, the VIX, this means we are
getting both the opportunity and the risk
that we like and we choose to accept as
traders.
Our market cap filters when we're going
through our processes will put us in the
right ballpark for volatility.
But we should always double-check it and
make sure that we are getting an
acceptable level of volatility for both
our opportunity and risk.
As Chris Quill pointed out in his classes
on foundations of portfolio management
earlier in the PTM video series.
With earnings growth, we want to be long
or seeking to be long, the highest
percentage earnings growth.
And with shorts, we want to be seeking to
be short, the lowest percentage earnings
growth.
And ideally, we want our earnings growth
over the upcoming two periods to show
sequential characteristics.
And of course, we want to be doing this
with good timing.
However, when we are going through our
quantitative processes at the sector level
for earnings growth,
if we can't find our ideal sequentially
positive or sequentially negative earnings
growth profiles,
we may be willing to accept non-ideal
earnings growth profiles as the next best
thing.
And of course, we always have the choice
to go and look for long and short ideas in
other sectors
if we can't find the ideal earnings growth
profiles that we like.
With revenue growth, we like to see the
top line of our company,
our forward-looking estimates for revenue
growth for the top line.
We want to see growth estimates for longs
that are expanding.
And for shorts, we want to see evidence of
forward-looking estimates that are
contracting.
When it comes to price earnings ratio and
PEG ratio, so with valuation,
starting with price earnings ratio,
we want to see evidence from the PE that
money likes our potential long ideas
or dislikes our potential short ideas.
Through a trader's interpretation of price
earnings ratio,
we would much rather have the market on
our side than not on our side.
With PEG ratio, we want to see evidence
from the valuation gap
both in PEG ratio and in PE ratio that we
actually have an opportunity in the stock.
So for long ideas, this would be the
difference in the gap between PE2 and PE1
of a positive outlier and then making an
assumption that in period 2,
the stock will trade on the same PE
multiple as in period 1.
And the difference is the gap between the
PE2 and the PE1.
So this gives us a potential price target
over the next period.
For long ideas with PEG ratio, the
difference between PEG 2 and PEG 1
tells us the opportunity in the stock if
the market pays the same PEG ratio
in period 2 as they're paying in period 1
and also may give us a sense of a price
target over that period,
similar to the price earnings ratio.
With shorts, we don't read too much into
PEGs
because as we realized with negative
earnings growth profiles,
PEGs can just be all over the place
and the numbers have little inference to
the reality of the stock.
When it comes to price earnings ratio or
shorts,
when we have a negative EPS, we don't read
too much into the PE ratio and its
importance.
However, when EPS is positive, but we have
negative earnings growth,
PE profiles and the gap between PE2 and
PE1 tells us what the potential
opportunity is for the short
in terms of the change in the multiple
being the same in period 2 as it is in
period 1
and therefore the potential downside in
the stock over the period.
And of course, with shorts, when we're
doing our quantitative processing,
we're looking at our forward-looking
metrics.
We always have to think of it in the
context of our five phases.
So our starting point, as always, in quant
processing is to identify what the market
likes and dislikes.
So we have our 11 numbers.
We have stock price, market cap, EPS0,
EPS1, EPS2, earnings growth 1 and 2, PE 1
and 2, and PEG 1 and 2.
We download the data, we go through the
downloaded data,
and our first step is to cleanse the data
and create our own robust sector.
We must always get to a point where we
have a very high degree of confidence
that the numbers are correct and that the
sector data is as close to a reflection of
reality as possible.
Then we identify the earnings growth
profiles, the PE and PEG premiums and
discounts,
and we make sure we are comfortable with
our conclusions.
We come to the conclusion that there are
positive and negative outliers and what is
in between.
So possible turnarounds or X growth
stories or boring nothing stocks.
Then we move on to ask the question of
why.
So we move on to the evidence phase.
So we look at quantitative backwards
looking evidence.
So we first look at the most obvious
backwards looking quantitative or
accounting metrics.
We start with revenue growth.
We also look at gross margins or gross
profit ratio.
We look at the pre-tax profit ratio.
And we also look at net after-tax margins
or the after-tax ratio.
We also look for evidence to our forward
looking quants via our backwards looking
quants in the areas of enterprise value,
EBIT and EBITDA, EV over EBIT and EV over
EBITDA.
So we include these measures to our
positive and negative outliers.
And we keep asking the question of why
money likes and dislikes certain stocks in
the sector.
We are always trying to figure out why the
market likes or dislikes particular
stocks.
This is an evidence phase in which we
learn about the stocks, what is driving
the valuation, revenue growth and earnings
growth.
If it is not a predictor, it is backwards
looking information, always remember that
it's backwards looking information that
potentially confirms our forward looking
estimates.
We then do further work in our backwards
looking quant or accounting metrics by
moving on from simply looking at the
metrics on the profit and loss statement.
We also look at the balance sheet and we
look at the combo ratios between the
balance sheet and the profit and loss
statement.
And we also look at the cash flow
Now in the PTM video series, we learned
the balance sheet and the balance sheet
profit and loss combo metrics for
backwards looking financial statement
analysis.
We learned that in the context of
turnarounds, X growth names and possible
value traps.
However, they can all be used in your
regular analysis when doing your deep
dives on classic, longs and shorts.
So you should absolutely use these
processes.
Always follow the processes.
forward looking quant identification or
discovery first backwards looking quant
evidential second, and then move on to
forward looking qualitative assessment.
So to understand this visually, we have
our quant discovery or identification area
or phase.
That is all predicated on forward looking
work using forward looking valuation and
forward looking estimates.
Then we have our quantitative evidence
phase, which is backwards looking
financial statements.
And then we have our qualitative
assessment, our qualitative drivers, which
is both backwards and forwards looking
KPIs and management operating plan.
So here now we add in to our overall
fundamental analysis evolution.
We add in the descriptors for every part
of our microeconomic processes that we
use.
So when we identify, finally identify our
positive and negative outliers, that is
all quantitative work and it's discovery
and evidence work.
When we are learning the stock
information, this is also evidence work.
So this is where the quantitative
processes and the qualitative processes
overlap.
When we are looking at backwards looking
accounting metrics, this is, of course,
defined as quantitative work.
However, because it's backwards looking,
it is also working on evidence to support
forward looking valuation and to
potentially discover what is behind
revenue growth and earnings growth for
positive and negative outliers.
But when we are doing qualitative
processes, qualitative work on a stock,
naturally, by doing that, we are also
engaging in learning about the stock's
information.
So this is also evidence work.
And this can be both backwards and
forwards looking.
And when we are doing qualitative work on
a stock and on a sector, we are also
looking forwards and we are identifying
key performance indicators.
So with KPIs, we are identifying the
drivers of the drivers of the business
behind revenue and earnings.
And with identifying catalysts, we are
identifying what is going to drive the
stock and what is going to drive
valuation.
But this next part of the microeconomic
processes that we utilize is coming up in
the next part of the PTM video series.
We're going to be obviously looking at
qualitative processes.
Now, you'll recall that we looked at a
theoretical long short portfolio and that
was built all based on earnings growth
profiles.
So we had our theoretical 10 stock,
$100,000 portfolio with a net long bias
that's non beta adjusted, but it was all
built on the assumption of only looking at
earnings growth profiles.
So we obviously jumped the gun here.
There is still a lot more work to do if we
build a portfolio only based on earnings
growth profiles, which, by the way, we
will never do this assumes that we haven't
done any qualitative processes at all.
And that we don't want our stocks to move
in the next 20 to 60 days.
So our stocks don't actually have
catalysts.
As traders and portfolio managers, we want
to know what is behind the numbers, what
is behind the revenue growth, what is
behind the earnings growth, what is
driving that, and also what is driving
valuation.
And what we also want to know is we want
to know if there are catalysts that are
going to move the stock within our time
horizon.
Remember, we must always know the
difference between a trade idea and an
investment idea.
We absolutely must never forget that a
trade idea is not an investment idea nor a
day trade.
We are operating in the 20 to 60 day time
horizon.
We are long short portfolio managers.
We want to be right by 60 days out.
We do not come up with investment ideas
and we do not turn our trade ideas into
investments.
We must know what is driving the numbers,
what is behind the numbers.
We must know, we must understand before we
even go into a trade, what is going to
move the needle within our time horizon on
the numbers.
What behind the numbers is going to move
the needle and what is the catalyst or
catalysts that are going to achieve that.
And we must never forget also that the
quality of our ideas is paramount.
Never forget the importance that the
quality of our trade ideas plays in the
overall process of building and managing a
long-short portfolio.
So this is why we go through all of our
processes, not just, for example, going
through the identification stage of the
quantitative process,
finding something that is high PE and high
earnings growth, and then turning it into
a position.
We obviously have to go through a lot more
processes and do a lot more work than just
that stage.
That is just an identification process.
It's a discovery process.
And then we move on to the next part of
our quantitative process.
The next part of our quant phase, which is
evidence.
We look to backwards looking quantitative
metrics for evidence to support the
forward looking quant.
And in the process, we are obviously, even
at that stage, learning about the stock
information.
And even then, we don't stop and turn
something into a position, turn a trade
idea into a position.
At that stage, it's not even a trade idea
yet.
We then move on to the qualitative
processes.
We identify the drivers behind the
numbers.
And this helps us understand and pinpoint
what is going to drive the valuation of
the stock going forwards.
And what is going to drive price.
And not only that, it's going to help us
understand and even pinpoint what is going
to move the needle
within our time horizon.
A trade idea is not a trade idea if you
have only done the quantitative work.
The definition of a trade idea, a complete
trade idea, is when you have done both the
quantitative
and the qualitative assessment.
So, with that being said, let's move on to
the next part of the PTM video series.
Let's move on to the qualitative
processes.